this is the new Samsung Galaxy s5 i want  to show you five things about it that  are new as this phone was just announced  today for starters it's a larger display  this is 5.1 inches old galaxy s4 only  five inches also you have a fingerprint  sensor here on the bottom sounds like  some fingerprint sensors we've seen on  other phones as well there's more on the  back there's a heart rate monitor you  put your finger here and the phone will  tell you whether or not you're about to  have a cardiac episode or sometime  there's obviously a better camera  there's also better materials along the  back case of the phone answering some of  the criticisms from galaxy s4 and galaxy  s3 that they appeared and felt a bit too  plasticky and you know check this out  it's also water resistant up to 30  minutes and up to one meter of water  this thing will actually be just fine as  most all those other phones that if you  know you drop it in a bar bathroom well  curtains